Brandel Chamblee is joining us now from
Aaron Hills here on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing there Brandel I'm terrific
thanks how you doing tell me about this
kid Xander Shah flea that's sitting at
the top of the leaderboard he just
dropped a shot but tell me about this
kid our young he's inexperienced besides
John Romney the second youngest rookie
on the PGA Tour he's done a little bit
of you know cool things in ammeter golf
you know he won the cal state ammeter he
lost in the finals the western hander
but he's only he's only had one top-10
on the PGA Tour he's still sort of fun
in his he like so to speak but he hits
at nine miles and because the golf
courses is so different to what you'd
expect at a US Open we we expected to
see some surprises and it's not unusual
to have somebody pop up early in the US
open like this well this is now the
second time in three years where the
conversation is the Golf Course is not
what you'd expect at a US Open so maybe
is this now what we should expect at a
US Open Randall I guess you know the the
US Open is sort of acquiesce to the fact
that you know guys hit it a long way and
hit it crooked and so they're they're
making the fairways larger they're
making the rough less penal so you know
yeah I think we're getting some
surprises I'll say this though Xander
even though he hasn't played
particularly well this year in the last
two weeks that he has played he's found
form you know he hit it as straight as
he's hit it all year long at Colonial
which was two events ago he was the
second longest player in the field of
FedEx trains you last week and he's
putted the best he's putted all year so
he comes into the US Open with some form
and again this isn't this isn't a golf
course that unless you think about what
it is that you're doing
in other words playing in the US Open if
you can somehow keep that out of your
mind the Golf Course doesn't attack you
you can attack it you know the fairways
are 50 40 50 60 70 yards wide and if you
can hit it out there you've got short
iron to all these greens when the
yardage that people are talking about
seven you know seven thousand seven
hundred yards long or whatever it's not
playing anywhere near that Brandel
Chamblee of the golf channel joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show the featured
group of day rosin McIlroy it's it's
kind of looking ugly what's going on
with some of the
bold face names for with those guys and
dustin johnson and jordan Spieth what
can you tell me about this right well De
Rose and Johnson have all suffered from
injuries it's even even though it wasn't
really talked about much when Rose was
playing in the final round of the
Masters she was grabbing his back and
favoring his back and he has a history
in the last year or so of having a bad
back Jason Day similarly Rory McIlroy
similarly Dustin Johnson hurt himself at
the Masters split them down the stairs
and you know with the birth of his
second child you can you can well
imagine and understandably so that he's
distracted so you know again a lot of
the top players coming in here we're
either injured out of sorts or
distracted by sort of family obligations
you know it's just in this case with
Dustin Johnson obviously with the case
with Phil Mickelson not even be in here
so a very weird us openness for well in
the conversation or at least the the
note that it is the first major sands
fill / Tigers since the 94 meters and
you know the conversation about Phil
there this week is what Randle well I
think everybody understands you know
he's always been big family man but you
know listen you know he's he's at that
age where the window closes so fast and
the fact that he had played really
really well at FedEx st. Jude and the
golf course in terms of finding a golf
course that was sort of fit filled
because Phil's always been a little wild
off the tee actually really wild off the
tee I don't know if he could have found
a golf course that's fitting any better
and you know he has a chance to join
five men who completed the career Grand
Slam so you know personally I it
wouldn't have surprised me if he would
have just watched it you know face
planned his family watched it that
morning and teed off and gone about his
business but you know to each his own
nobody's fault in him for what he did
but the event certainly misses him and
the the conversation about tiger around
averin Hills is what Brandon you know
worried actually you know they you know
I think a lot of people were you know
we just sort of sad a tiger wasn't
playing well and that he was injured now
submits it's turned to just worry about
his well-being you know I think
everybody in the world can read between
the lines they can sort of guess what's
going on and know how serious it is and
you know golf is is way way on the back
burner now it's just you know hopefully
he gets his life back in order and can
put the pieces back together and enjoy
you know some semblance of a life a
normal life and and if that includes
golf well even better yet because who
wouldn't like to see Tiger Woods come
out here and have some semblance of a
nice little run sometime in his forties
well I mean Brandel I mean you you you
know better than anybody else certainly
from from the golf world and just me
being a young guy sitting on the Sports
Center set as Tiger was ascending and in
dominating I always thought you know and
I did actually have these conversations
with Stuart Scott and my other
colleagues back in the day that what
would Tiger look like when he hit his
40s right like what would his career
argue mean when he was healthy and when
he was young and right exactly that's
when we ran this kind of like just just
to extrapolate it out and we none of us
at all what nobody thought that what
might be fall him was not just physical
we all assumed that you know you get
older the mental aspect I Jordan is the
only guy that I could ever remember to
be in the conversation about what was
going on between the temples to focus
the drive the fact that that is now in
question I just I just can't believe it
I really can't just jockey no nobody
nobody can you know put put the most
recent events that took place out of the
picture and if you just look at the golf
that he had and you know it be the
equivalent of Michael Jordan coming back
late as career making another comeback
and not being able to make a free throw
I mean that's how how much is his game
has deteriorated you know between his
ears you know I said it for her eons now
that the end of his career will be as
sad at the beginning was brilliant you
know he ruined
body that the game of golf ever seen he
ruined the best golf swing that the game
of golf has ever seen and he did that
because he wanted to have the perfect
body and because he was in search of the
perfect golf swing it's not so much that
he barked up the wrong tree looking for
the perfect golf swing
he said he barked up every tree and you
know if there's you know if there's
lessons to learn from Tiger Woods on the
way up and all these players are sort of
you know sort of a nod to the diet that
he was there's also lessons to learn
from Tiger Woods on the way down you
cannot have seen it you cannot turn golf
cannot turn sport into science and it's
been tried a million times it never
works you know it may you know it may
seduce players into thinking that's
going to work for a little while but
sooner or later they destruct and I've
seen it way too many times and I've
never ever seen it turn out posit
Brandel Chamblee of the golf channel
before I let you go Paul Casey just
birdied to go 7-under Rickie Fowler will
be teeing off at 7-under in the third
hour of this show best you can with 54
holes for Fowler and the rest of his
groups to go in this US Open how do you
see this playing out over the weekend
well I'd keep my eye on Brooks Kefka you
know he's a he's a mammoth talent he's
only won once on a PGA Tour but he's
capable of hitting it straight shot
after shot after shot and hit that 334
yards he's capable of stringing together
great rounds he's dangerous not talking
too much about him Rickie Fowler
statistically is the best player on the
PGA Tour all around Paul Casey is way
too talented to have only one wants on
the PGA Tour but he has a history of
playing himself into position and then
backing up very quickly getting himself
into position and backing up again as a
history of doing that he even did it
today you know he started out poor
birdie and they went bogie par triple
bogey and then he's made four birdies in
a row at 17 18 1 & 2 so you know he's up
and down he's a very talented player but
he'll slow down and getting very
deliberate and loses rhythm it has
happened a lot he's 39 years of age I'll
be be curious to see if he can keep his
rhythm through the weekend Brandl thank
you for the call
preciate it enjoy the rest of the
weekend and have a good one
thanks so much rich thank you the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy